Je n'ai pas pu utiliser mon casier pendant des semaines parce que le cadenas
me rappelait celui que j'avais mis sur mes lèvres
quand un SDF dans la rue
m'a regardé d'un regard qui cherchait simplement
l'assurance qu'il était digne d'être regardé.
Je tenais plus à ce qu'il se passait sur mon iPhone
qu'à lui donner de quoi manger.
Quand une femme au gala de charité
m'a dit: « Je suis si fière de vous.
Cela doit être si difficile d'enseigner à ces élèves pauvres et en difficulté. »
Je me suis mordu les lèvres, parce qu'apparemment son argent
avait plus d'importance que la dignité de nos élèves.
On passe tant de temps
à écouter les choses qu'on nous dit
qu'on ne prête pas attention à celles qu'on ne nous dit pas.
Le silence est le résidu de la peur.
Il sent vos défauts
il paralyse votre langue.
C'est l'air qui s'échappe de votre poitrine
parce qu'il ne se sentait pas en sécurité dans vos poumons.
Le silence, c'est le génocide du Rwanda. Le silence, c'est l'ouragan Katrina.
C'est ce qu'on entend quand il n'y a plus assez de sacs mortuaires.
C'est le son une fois que la corde est nouée.
C'est les cendres. C'est les chaînes. C'est les privilèges. C'est la douleur.
On n'a plus le temps de choisir ses combats
quand les combats nous ont déjà choisis.
Je ne laisserai pas le silence enrober mon indécision.
Je dirai à Christian qu'il est un lion,
un havre de courage et d'intelligence.
Je demanderai à ce SDF comment il s'appelle
et s'il passe une bonne journée, parce que quelquefois
tout le monde veut être humain.
Je dirai à cette femme que mes élèves peuvent parler de transcendantalisme
comme s'ils s'appelaient Thoreau
et que ce n'est pas parce que vous venez de regarder un épisode de « Sur écoute »
que vous pouvez penser connaître mes jeunes.
Alors cette année,
au lieu de renoncer à quelque chose,
je vivrai chaque jour comme si un micro
était placé sous ma langue,
une scène pour la face cachée de mon inhibition.
Car qui a besoin d'une tribune
quand il suffit juste de sa voix ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)